gérer des mes dettes et je suis parti à
cuba je me repose comme si j'étais chez
moi
sauf que si des paysans comme si j'étais
en vacances paye mes études
voilà ce cargo rythme pharma décrit
comme les effets secondaires de ces
essais de médicaments sur des cobayes
humains
le problème selon l'expert en éthique
que nous avons consultés c'est que cette
pub banalise les véritables effets
secondaires ce genre d'études cliniques
poudre entre autres et maux de tête ou
des nausées aux personnes testées les
conséquences que publicité devrait
clairement souligné aux éventuels
participants
recevez 3400 $ dans cette pub on voit
bien que l'indemnité offert représente
une sorte d' appât qui va attirer les
participants éventuels aux tests
hors la loi est très claire l'argent
offert contre la participation à ce
genre d'étude ne doit servir qu'à
compenser les pertes financières des
participants recevaient 250 $
additionnels pour chaque patient referee
le commentaire du professeur de droit
que nous avons consultés
comment s'assurer que la personne dire
faire un patient n'a pas exercé une
pression et du sur elle bref selon nos
trois experts
voilà une campagne de publicité
agressive qui manque nettement vécu